[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour cette vidéo de la rentrée en
compagnie de Sophie bonjour Julien
Sophie Miss plume qui nous accompagne
aujourd'hui parce qu'on va encore se
faire un petit documentaire allez c'est
pour la
rentrée notre expert en communication
scientifique aujourd'hui va appliquer
ses talents
exper
attention va appliquer ses talents à un
documentaire un autre documentaire la
dernière fois c'était un documentaire de
1993 cette fois c'est un documentaire de
1925 ça va donc être une vidéo de la
mauvaise foi le fond du tiroir ah
ouient on va on va complètement
désinguer on va désinguer un
documentaire de 1925 ça c'est pas
correct ça c'est pas vrai ça c'est pas
comme ça
mauvaisefoie.com mais non évidemment que
non évidemment que non ce qui va être
intéressant donc avec ce documentaire de
1925 ça va être de voir bah qu'est-ce
que les gens qui ont fait ce film
considérit comme étant important de
communiquer à propos des dinosaures
parce qu'il s'agit du premier du tout
premier document
sur les dinosaures jamais réalisés en
tout cas le tout premier dont on a
encore des traces il a été fait en 1925
c'est un documentaire allemand et la
version que vous allez voir ce n'est pas
la version allemande c'est la version
qui a été traduite en anglais et qui a
été remontée par des Américains mais du
coup les les images sont différentes ou
pas il y a eu des cuts on sait pas on a
la vieille version allemande à un
endroit nul part nulle part donc ça
c'est la seule et unique copie qui
restait du film elle était au Muséum
d'Amsterdam au Muséum de de cinéma
d'Amsterdam euh et elle a été restaurée
en 2015 quand ils l'ont retrouvé h et
c'est c'est tout ce qu'on a c'est on n
pas beaucoup plus que ça d'accord donc
si ça se trouve la version allemande
était différente c'est c'est très
probable que la version bah elle était
en allemand déjà oui ça aurait été
fichrement plus difficile pour nous
c'est ce qui est du coup une information
intéressante dans la mesure où quand on
regarde en fait le enfin si on scroll un
petit peu on n pas encore regardé le
documentaire pour l'instant mais si on
regarde un petit peu là le la bande en
bas ce qu'on y voit en fait c'est ce
sont essentiellement du dinosaure
nord-américain voyez on a un adrosaur
enfin un beau bec de canard ici on a bon
ça c'est un iguanodon à la limite ça
c'est européen ça va là on a un diméodon
enfin du moins un de ces pécosores qu'on
ne retrouve qu'en Amérique du Nord là on
a un TR un
cératopsien bref on a surtout de la
faune nord-américaine quoi stgosor tout
ça c'était pas connu à l'époque en
Europe à part iguanodon tout ça c'était
pas connu en Europe donc ils se sont ils
se sont arrêtés sur la faune
essentiellement américaine et la raison
pour ça ce qui est le premier truc
intéressant à propos de ce film c'est la
raison pour ça c'est qu'ils se sont
énormément basés sur les œuvres de
Charles
hernight donc les les magnifiques
peintures de Charles hernight par
exemple quand on regarde ce tricératops
enfin ce cératopsien là voyez ça sa tête
très caractéristique avec toutes ses
pointes qui est et ses cornes très très
droites là on le retrouve bien en fait
dans le film juste ici là c'est
exactement la même posture voyez ou bien
un peu un autre endroit du film on va
voir le
ouais là il y a le diétrodon évidemment
et puis surtout il y a il y a un truc
qui est vraiment très caractéristique
c'est cette peinture là où on voit un
dinosaure thopode qui a l'air d'être un
soit un Trex soit un Allosaurus je sais
pas trop parce qu'à l'époque ils étaient
pas ils étaient tous les deux pains avec
trois doigts à l'époque char c'est fin
19e donc c'est c'est vieux c'est vieux
c'était probablement la seule ressource
pictographique accessible à l'époque en
tout cas mondialement accessible à
l'époque et donc c'est c'est un
dinosaure théropode un grand dinosaure
théropode en train de de dévorer une
queue voyez la queue d'un d'un dinosaure
et là ce qu'on a ici c'est exactement ça
dans ce
documentaire c'est à ce niveaaul voilà
ah oui la peinture reprise trait pour
trait c'est quasiment la même ure donc
c'est c'est assez marrant en fait de de
voir ce documentaire qui a été fait en
Europe mais du coup comme la seule
ressource qu'ils avaient pour faire le
documentaire c'était les peintures de de
Charles Knight donc c'est ça c'est déjà
intéressant et du coup il figure une
faune qui est essentiellement américaine
d'où l'intérêt des Américains pour ce
documentaire je suppose ouais donc c'est
la version animée des peintures de
Charles
Knight donc on va voir si ce
documentaire il est il était bien pour
l'époque est-ce que c'était un bon
document
ça étant donné les connaissances de
l'époque est-ce que faut se remettre
dans le dans l'esprit de l'époque avec
oui les idées sur les dinosaures de
l'époque oui très romantique diff très
très romantique très différente de
maintenant ça va être marrant et c'est
en noir et blanc évidemment c'est en
noir et blanc et enmué enmué c'est pour
ça que vous avez les textes entre les
enfin c'est vieux quoi l'histoire du
cinéma dans un documentaire de
dinosaures
j'aime pourra mettre la musique là de
l'audio
connard
le même grain de film alors en plus
c'est allemand donc on pourrait faire
petitte bulles de texte avec le faux
accent allem the CS
appr alors le film s'intitule y million
years ago déjà rien que le titre à
l'époque ils en avaient aucune
idée il y a la la datation absolue ça
n'existe pas en 1925 don tout ce qu'on
tout ce qu'on de l'âge de ces bêtes là
finalement
c'est c'est c'est c'est du pifomètre
hein oui c'est vrai il se disaient bon
allez c'est c'est vieux on va leur
donner quelques millions d'années c'est
ça bah c'est et finalement ils étaient
pas toujours complètement à côté de la
plaque en tout cas pour les périodes la
préhistoire récente par exemple bah
quand on pense à l'enfant de Tang par
exemple qui a été découvert bah en
1924 à l'époque il lui avait donné un
âge bah à la louche entre 2 et 4
millions d'années et ils étaient pas
loin oui ils étaient pas loin du tout et
ça c'était juste basé sur les les
vitesses de sédimentation donc on avait
des formations on savait dans quel ordre
ces formations s'étaient formé parce que
la même si on avait pas d'âge absolu la
stratigraphie relative on l'avait on
savait on savait que au début il y avait
le Paléozoïque ensuite il y avait le
Mésozoïque qu'à l'intérieur du
Mésozoïque on avait d'abord le Trias
puis le Jurassique puis le Crétacé tout
ça on l'avait et à la fin on avait le
cénnozoïque donc tout ça on l'avait
c'est juste que bah la seule le seul
accès aux dates absolu bah c'était juste
calculer combien de temps il faut pour
que toute la CRÉ du Crétacé se dépose en
gros et ça nous donne tant de millions
d'années plus ou moins relative avec des
grosses des grosses marges d'erreurs
problème c'est que s'il vous manque une
couche dans ces cas-là vous le savez pas
et vous pouvez pas rajouter cette couche
là pour votre datation relative c'est ça
et puis bah c'est pas la crée du Crétacé
on en reparlera un peu plus tard mais la
CRÉ du Crétacé c'est pas déposé partout
au Crétacé en Amérique du Nord une
couche en Amérique du Nord c'est pas de
la CRÉ qu'ils ont c'est de la c'est de
c'est de la c'est du gré enfin même pas
c'est des c'est des marnes des Badlands
puisque c'est là qui trouvent les
dinosaures oui effectiv donc nous en
France nous enfin en Allemagne ils ont
de la CRÉ au Crétacé parce que c'était
la mer mais par contre en Amérique du
Nord ils ont surtout des Badlands ils
ont une petite une petite mer intérieure
qui passe au milieu mais ils ont surtout
des Badlands h donc c'est pas la même
vitesse de dépôt pour l'un et pour
l'autre parce que les milieux terrestres
généralement ça se dépose beaucoup plus
lentement et épisodiquement que la CR se
dépose beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
régulièrement oui ça ça tombe au fond de
l'eau donc déjà on peut on peut
apprécier déjà le fait qu'ils aient
tenté de balancer une date 50 millions
ouais c'est pas si
loin c'est pas si loin des des 66
millions d'années du coup qui nous
ramènerait autant des dinosaures sachant
qu'il y a pas que des dinosaures dans le
documentaire ah du coup ils ont ont tout
mis ensemble dans le même paquet ouais
c'est un peu d'accord bon on va
peut-être qu'ils ont mis des dates entre
deux tu sais
pas on va voir on va voir allez allez il
y a de la musique aussi la musque
musquecord je pense qu'elle est pas
d'époque alors les scientifiques sont
d'accord pour dire qu'il y a que la
terre doit être au moins 50 millions
d'années vieille de 50 millions d'années
ah oui donc donc là on est même pas sur
l'âge des dinosaures on est sur l'âge de
la Terre 50 millions d'années c'est
waouh c'est réent he on était loin on
était loin d'accord je pensais que
c'était l'âge des dinosaure mais là non
en fait alors on pense que la Terre a
été précédemment partie d'une autre
planète et qui s'est cassé et qui du
coup est parti euh vivre son petit
chemin son petit Bonom parti d'une autre
planète qui qui s'est détaché quand elle
était encore à l'état de
nébuleuse nébuleuse c'est pas les
étoiles normalement si non c'est pas
grave d'accord c'est et on nous montre
donc bon en gros ça s'est détaché d'une
autre planète ok donc ça c de cette
nébuleuse magnifique
sublime alors les la révolution continue
de la terre a causé la condensation
graduelle d'une boule gigantesque sa
condensation graduelle en une boule
gigantesque on voit même la lune se
former et attention effet spécial ça
tour on a fait tourner le le dessin bah
c'est bon après c'est les techniques de
l'époque hein voilà et du coup là h
effet spécial attention morphing moring
un morphing et donc le processus de
refroidissement a demandé beaucoup
beaucoup de milliers d'années milliers
oui oui certainement ça fait beaucoup de
milliers d'années mais c'est dire mais
là on on constate donc 50 millions
d'années pour eux c'était l'âge de la
Terre avec quelques milliers d'années
pour pour le refroidissement et après on
commence à se balader avec les
dinosaures d'accord ok bah la la
datation absolue sera inventée donc avec
le carbone 14 que dans les années 1950
ouais et on voit à quel point ça a tout
changer hein on voit à quel point ça a
tout changer parce que
ouais on pouvait pas il y avait quandce
qu's ont déclaré que la terre avait plus
de 4 milliards d'années
euh quand est-ce qu'ils l'ont déclaré je
saurais pas dire je parce que
visiblement c'est plus
récent c'est plus récent mais c'estàdire
que la après le la plus vieille roche
datée qui est un zircon qui est inclus
dans une autre roche conglomératique h
ça ça a été daté dans les années 2000
voir
2010 le le zircon à le zircon à 4,1
milliards d'années c'est ouais mais on
savait déjà qu'il y avait plus de 4
milliard d'années avant ça oui on le
savait déjà avant
ça de quand ça date moi je dirais que ça
date faut faut remonter à l'utilisation
de
de des des méthodes qui utilisent
l'uranium et les isotopes la série
isotopique de l'uranium donc ça doit
dater des années 60 70 bon on est allé
voir sur Wikipédia c'est en allant voir
les météorites c'est en étudiant les
météorites du coup qui sont qui sont
dans notre système solaire qu'ils ont
déterminé du coup un âge à 4,5 milliards
d'années et c'était en
1956 les météorites qui sont tombés sur
terre du coup parce que du coup ils ont
pu les dater avec l'uranium justement
oui oui oui les météorites qui sont
tombés sur Terre à l'époque il savaiit
pas encore comment aller les chercher
puis même maintenant B si on peut aller
les chercher maintenant en 1956 il
pouvait pas 1956 il pouvait pas mais il
y avait déjà des âge qui qui avait été
proposé à plusieurs milliards d'années
bien avant ça en 1927 là on a déjà un
âge à plusieurs milliards d'années qui
avait été proposé par Holmes basé aussi
sur des sur le du coup le la la
désintégration d'éléments radioactifs
qui ne pouvait pas prendre moins de
plusieurs milliards d'années comme
l'uranium B c'est ça mais avant
visibblement en 1800 quelque chose là
ils avaient proposé un truc aussi là
reste là et du coup là en bas de la
page
bwoods il a il avait calculé jusqu'à 2,2
milliard d'années déjà ouais et et avant
encore il y avait un autre qui avait
aussi mais mais le problème de ces
résultats qui était très très éloigné
des croyances de l'époque j'imagine
c'est que personne les prenait au
sérieux bah et puis c'était balbusciant
c'està-dire que là il y avait une énorme
variation entre les résultats que chacun
trouvait dépendant du l'élément
radioactif qu'ils utilisaient donc h bon
disons que c'était déjà à l'époque
balancer 50 millions d'années c'était
peut-être déjà c'était déjà pas mal
balancer une date tout court d'ailleurs
céit finalement il sa ouais ils en
savaient pas grand-chose ils en savaient
pas grandchose mais du coup on était à 2
ans hein 1927 on était à 2 ans de la
d'un âge en milliard d'années quand même
ouais ouais cétait pas très loin mais
c'est ouais ça ne sera confirmé qu'en
1956 du
coup il n'y avait pas d'homme ou de
bêtes qui avait possiblement pu vivre à
cette époque il suppose que c'était très
chaud premers habitants de la terre étai
des trilobites et les les méduses oui
les méduses et les trilobites voilà les
méduses et des trilobites trilobit oh
attention ça bouge les trilobit il bouge
c'est animé c'est trop bien on dirait
sais un un tableau métallique pas avec
les les trilobit comme des aimants tu
sais c'est exactement ça en fait si tu
regardes processus
d'évolution par évolution certains ont
appris à marcher à ramper et sont
devenus des animaux terrestres comme ce
ou là VO là il y a il y a un saut on
passe des TR on pass rapidement puis on
a zappé les plantes c'est marrant les
techniques qu'ils ont utilisé donc tout
à l'heure on avait le panneau enfin on
aurait dit un panneau métallique avec
les trilobit en aimant et enfin aimanté
depuis l'autre côté du panneau et du
coup ça c'est ça mais là du là c'est du
c'est du stop motion avec avec juste du
papier c'est du papier ouais c'est un
dessin en fait c'est un peu comme quand
vous faites des découpage et que vous
collez ça et vous amusez à avoir un truc
articulier c'est exactement
ça en 1900 enfin dans les années 20 il
connaissait il faisait déjà du stop
motion h c'est c'est la mégaura là qui
essaie de représenter on l'avait déjà à
l'époque on dirait on dirait une méganor
ah oui à l'époque bah c'est du
Carbonifère les la paléontologie est
quasiment née à cause de la de de
l'industrie minière donc et notamment de
minage du charbon
h et là c'est vu qu'on est en Allemagne
oui c'est obligé qu'il représente les
les méganuras de la Roure et oui
évidemment sacré bol quand même ça doit
impressionner quand on est couvr non
ouais mais c'est par contre ce qu'il y a
de dommage c'est qu'il y a pas de notion
d'échelle du coup si tu
ouais libule géante ou tu sais pasjà
c'est une libule géante tu tu le vois
pas tu le vois pas que c'est que c'est
une libellule
géante c'est chouette au moins il y a un
peu de Faun local du coup qui est
représenté alors les forêts couvraent de
très grandes zones inondées par les
océans ouais là c'est typiquement le
bain saint minier qui est décrit he le
bassin le grand bassin minier du Nord de
la France et qui se continue sur les les
qui se continue sur la belle et jusqu'en
Allemagne et même jusqu'en Pologne
c'était une forêt qui était
régulièrement inondée par la mer et donc
à chaque fois que la donc la forêt se
laissait des des restes végétaux qui se
décomposaient et après était recouverte
par la mer qui a mené une couche de
sédiments sableux pouf ça vous fait un
filon de de houille un filon de charbon
un filon du gré un autre filon de ouille
à chaque fois que le cycle recommence
donc c'est c'est c'est le processus de
formation de de de cette de ce bassin
minier là qui est qui est expliqué ici
avec pour je sais quelle raison un ours
polaire à l'arrière pas un ours un ours
des cavernes qu'ils ont essayé de
dessiner peut-être un ours des cavernes
du coup mon avis à mon avis ils ont dit
il nous faut une image de fond ouais fa
un ours des caverne vas-y c'est c'est
c'est des cavernes c'est vieux ça
devrait le faire puis les forêts les
ourses et la période suivante qui est
l'âge de la CRÉ le Crétacé ouais donc on
transitionne carbonifè Crétacé voilà est
arrivé le temps des dinosaures qui sont
aujourd'hui complètement éteint euh
ouais c'est grosse transition du coup
transition carbonifère direct Crétacé le
GR on a bien sauté le permi in Trias
jurassique ça n'existe pas mais là aussi
encore une fois c'est un point de vue
mais c'est ce qu'ils ont vu c'est
européen c'est un point de vue qui est
assez européen on va dire oui puisque
par que oui tu tu as du Carbonifère et
tu as le Crétacé directement par-dessus
voilà dans le bassin minier c'est
exactement ça qui se passe effectivement
c'est on a la la créie donc Crétacé ça
veut dire il y avait c'est marrant parce
que j'avais vu un en en faisant des
recherches sur cette vidéo j'avais vu
qu'il y avait un Américain qui en
décryptant ce ce panneau là disait mais
pourquoi ils appellent ça le shalkk age
pouro oui parce que c'était l'ancien
terme du coup oui et parce que parce que
les pour les Américains c'est pas
évident que l'âge de la créie le
crétassé c'est c'est la même chose parce
que comme je l'ai dit pour mais il
connaissent pas cré pour eux c'est ch et
du coup crétassé ça veut rien
dire et puis c'est surtout qu'il y a pas
de Cré en Amérique il y a pas les dépôt
les dépôts du Crétacé ne sont pas de la
CRÉ en Amérique exement donc pour lui ça
voulait rien dire pourquoi ils appellent
ça le c'est un mot français donc c'est
intéressant c'est intéressant et donc
ouis là là on voit par contre le le
point de vue européen bien comme il faut
h alors là des dinosaures c'est là où on
commence à là la musique devient tambour
et tout alors dans les Anciens des Jours
quand les nuits étaient froid Volstead
Volstead was unnown c'est quoi Volstead
du coup qu'un Volstead alors après
recherche trouve il se trouve que
Volstead on coupe directement ou
Volstead apparemment ça ferait référence
à la prohibition en Amérique la loi
Volstead qui a eu lieu de 1920 en 193 3
c'est la fameuse période d'Al capapon du
coup qui ouais qui faisait du trafic
d'alcool de contrebande entre autres
choses mais du coup du coup ce serait
une référence visiblement là purement
américaine du coup à la la prohibition
qui avait lieu à
l'époque curieux de d'introduire ça à ce
moment-là là ça RIM en fait c'est pour
ça
days ah c'est poétique c'est poétique
c'est poétique ouais mais alors
est-ce que est-ce que du coup tu
mettrais le 493 dans ton documentaire
juste pour je sais pas si j'aurais juste
pour que ça r est-ce que est-ce que tu
ferais ça dans un texte de vulgarisation
scientifique cher
experte non j'aurais pas de 493 làdedans
mais ferais-tu une référence au 493 mais
il faut faut voir que c'était
certainement
très cétait important pour les gens de
l'époque puis ça montre aussi que les
hommes ils étaient pas là à l'époque
j'imagine je sais pas peutêtre juste une
blague à l'époque il faisait déjà des
blagues pour vulgariser c'est possible
c'était pas c'était pas plus sérieux
parce que le dessin en dessous il est
marrant quand même ça c'est pas un
dinosaure c'est juste un dragon on
s'amuse à faire un truc là qui
ouais qui c'est un Pikachu avec ses yeux
il crache des éclairs ça c'est du dragon
c'est de la salamandre
ça du coup c'est Volstead là qui se
fait se fait attraper par le dragon non
éement il a des outils alors mais c'est
un gars avec un PNE regarde donc on a un
texte qui nous dit dans les dans les
jours anciens que les moins de 20000 ans
ne peuvent pas connaître en gros quand
les nuit était froide quand la loi sur
la prohibition n'était pas connue il y
avait un petit rugissement de dinosaures
non le plus petit regissement de
dinosaures vous donnerait des sures
froides vous donnerit des sures froides
comme c'est intéressant h on est parti
sur du poétique c'est sympa he
ahos les dinosaures rugissait déjà ouais
voyez on les faisait déjà rugir les
dinosaures comme des lions disait c'est
un gros truc alors ça doit ça doit avoir
un gros forcément rug voilà puis ça a
l'air méchant en plus c'est gros c'est
méchant c'est le bronthosaurus un animal
puissant qui normalement grandissait
enfin qui grandissait jusqu'à une taille
de 60 pied de long long
ouais donc encore des des trucs
primitifs d'Américains quoi des
métriques primitives d'Amérique il
dominer le monde de l'époque wou 60
pieds de long ça fait ça fait une
quinzaine de mètres 10 15 m si je me
rappelle bien à peu près ouais 15 m
ouais et qui devait régner sur le monde
donc brotosaurus qui était un des
dinosaures les plus connus à l'époque
qui a ensuite été synonymisé à
Apatosaurus mais qui a fait son retour
en 2014 ou 2015 donc bronosaurus est de
nouveau un taxon valide donc vous avez
de nouveau le droit de parler de
bronthosaurus mais c'est bien alors là
on nous offre une superbe image avec un
homme des cavernes chevauchant le fameux
bronosaur ce qui ce qui est très
intéressant dans la mesure où juste
avant il nous disait que c'était bien
avant le l'âge des hommes mais alors à
mon avis ça c'est juste pour te donner
l'échelle en fait tu crois que c'est
juste pour ouais c'était c'était où qui
disait bien avant l'âge des l'âge des
hommes enfin bref ils avaient justement
ils n'avaient pas commis cette erreur de
mélanger des humains et et des
dinosaures et finalement ils refont
l'erreur une slide après quoi c'est je
pense que juste pour la pour l'échelle
juste pour l'échelle ouais peut-être et
bronthosaurus qui est représenté euh et
a une sale tête hein ouais un peu
vindicatif et puis avec la queue qui
traîne bien au sol c'est un peu ça ça
correspond à l'image bah à l'époque il y
avait les tous ces films de monstres là
ouais on voyait un bronthosaur notamment
qui se baladait dans les rues de Londres
bah c'était dans le monde perdu je crois
dans le monde perdu dans le monde perdu
voit ce bronthosaur se baladaer dans les
rues de Londres et manger des
gens waouh ah ou oui c'était c'est
marrant il a une peti bosse aussi sur
les papates avant ah ouais bah c'est là
où il s'assie regarde tuas l'impression
que ça lui fait un dos comme
ça j' imagine que si tu mets la tête
comme ça et la queue
ou bon attention il est méchant ou là e
alors là on arrive sur a une bonne tête
le stop motion du stop motion ouais bah
pas mal c'est c'est assez fluide ça va
on voit un peu le le la jointure au
niveau du cou
ou il est repr présenter un peu pasau
hein comme c'est comme ça a étit comme
c'était le cas à l'époque il y a deux
boss tiens c'est marrant il y a des
modèles différents ouais c'est c'est
c'est bizarre ils se sont vraiment donné
du mal quoi ils ont trois modèles de
brontosur
différents pour lui faire faire
exactement les mêmes mouvements de tête
h la plupart des monstres de l'époque
étaient des ét des lzard qui pouvaient
se sentir chez eux dans l'eau aussi bien
que sur terre ah oui donc le le petit
saxophone avec sa tête là on dirait
presque qu'il va sortir le saxo
effectivement et puis il est bien assis
il a un petit TER de Godzilla un petit
TER de Godzilla mais peut-être juste
pour revenir sur le broosaur c'est vrai
qu'on n pas noté mais il est sur terre
HM sur terre et bien droit sur ses
pattes ça ça quand même pour une
représentation de 1925 c'est pas mal du
tout c'est pas mal c'est pas mal le coup
est un peu court sur celui-à c'est pas
le bronosur du coup bah si c'est
toujours le bronosur enfin tu mois
ilsappellent toujours ça le bronosur
mais ça c'est marrant le le coup il est
différent dans les trois sur les trois
modèles ils l'ont pas on fait ce qu'on
peut on fait ce qu'on peut mais là ouais
les les jambes sont bien droites le
corps est bien soutenu sur sur la terre
ferme bon le l'animal est représenté pas
loin de l'eau hein comme ils disent à
l'époque il pensait que c'était un
animal amphibie mais là ouais il tient
son poids le poids de son corps sur la
terre ferme et ça c'est quand même pas
mal pour les années pour les années 20
sachant qu'on va rétropédaler assez
sauvagement là-dessus plus tard donc on
passe à notre adrosaure saxophone notre
adrosaure lubrique
il a une tête de crocodile attends
ouis le bon becc de canard qui a les
adrosaur et les
iguanodontes les iguanodont qui ont
donné justement
le l'idée pour la première fois de
représenter les dinosaures comme des
genres de kangourous enfin avec cette
posture de kangourou c'est avec la
découverte de l'iguanodon c'est
oui parce qu'on pensait que ça te
tiendrait pas de bout sinon bah surtout
que les premiers dinosaures étaient
représentés tous quadrupèdes h donc
quand on a découvert iguanodon et qui
avait évidemment les jambes super
longues alors qu'il a les bras super
courts oui on pensait au kangourou du
coup immédiatement ça montrait qu'il
était bipède qu'il était capable de
locomotion bipède mais du coup il
comprenait pas trop comment ça pouvait
soutenir le poids de son corps tellement
c'était énorme du coup ils ont pensé à
cette posture kangourou de le mettre
avec la queue qui tient du coup qui fait
trépied voilà un iguanodon ait des
difficultés ne serait pas un très bon
animal de compagnie parce que ça mesuré
60 pieds du début à la fin il y a tout
qui fait 60 PI et du coup ils font tous
60 pieds onanodon qui bon alors arrivé
là on peut dire que niveau vulgarisation
c'était pas top ça veut dire qu'ils sont
grands on vient de vous dire qu'ils sont
grands on vous redit qu'ils sont grands
c'est même étant donné les connaissances
de l'époque là c'était pas top c'est
bien mais se contredire ENF c'est pas se
contredire mais dire tout fait 60 pieds
de long on s'en fout mettre l'iguanodon
à la même taille que le que le Bronz les
dates et les chiffres en général dans ce
documentaire mais non mais pourquoi
pourquoi avoir dit encore 60 pieds enfin
c'est je sais pas alors que c'est je
veux dire hiiguanodon en plus c'est un
des premiers trucs dont on a trouvé un
squelette réellement
complet même pas que un squelette
d'ailleurs et du coup on savait très
bien que ça faisait pas 60 pièces et
puis on voyait bien que c'était pas la
même taille que l'autre quand même bah
ouiiz brontosur tu as quand même une
sacrée taille mine de rien à côté c'est
c'est vachement plus long c'est deux ou
tr fois plus long quoi donc voilà donc
tu aurais pu au moins doubler le truc
cueux c'est curieux ces choix de de
vulgarisation alors ça aurait pas été un
bon animal de compagnie
c'est c'est mignon de le dire comme
ça je sais pas si c'était diriger vers
les enfants parce que finalement est-ce
qu'à l'époque les dinosaures ça plaisait
surtout aux enfants ah il est un petit
peu oh il mange tu as vu et regarde il
utilise son pouce il a un pouce tuas vu
il a un pouce opposable le fameux pouce
de l'iguanodon voilà le pousse auosable
le pousce en pointe que Owen avait mis
sur son nez un petit clin d'il caméra la
brisage du 4è mur
[Rires]
pause le
mazoo le
maosus il joue avec ses petits
camarades le masosaurus joue avec sestit
camarade il nous fait un Rocky hororure
showaud tu sais oh je veux pas voir
l'image
suivante ah là il y a a c'est quoi un
masosaurus un masosaurus je crois que
c'est un mosasaurus mais maléplé
ah je pense je pense hein puisquon est
censé être au crétass le
masosauris débuncage et pénitence la
nouvelle mascotte le masosaurus j'ai été
très très vilain
oh mon Dieu alors à quoi il ressemble le
masosaurus c'est quoi mais c'est
[Musique]
superchant ils se sont plantés dans la
réorganisation des trucs ils ont fait
des cuts ils ont coupé des trucs ils ont
pas mis les B il do manquer un non
clairement ils sont plantés là c'est pas
possible il doit manquer un bout et du
coup c'est là qu'elle le Permien qui
manquait tout à l'heure oui ils l'ont
ils l'ont je pense que les gens qui ont
ouais qui ont reconstié le film truc
mais pas dans le bon sens les gens qui
ont mononté le film ont dû se tromper
dans la réorganisation des framees parce
que là du coup tout à l'heure on se
plaignait qu'il manquait le Permien et
là à la place d'un mosazore on a un
animal du Permien qui est un diméro
alors est-ce que c'est vraiment un
dimétrodon parce que la tête est un
dimétrodon par contre la crête c'est
celle d'un
nedaphosor est-ce que à l'époque on
avait pas un peu confondu les deux non
non ah non parce qu'on a trouvé
immédiatement à l'époque de Cop c'est C
je crois qui a découvert dimétrodon
etaposaurus enfin ça s'est fait à
l'époque de Cop et March donc fin milieu
fin 19e siècle et à l'époque ils ont
découvert des squelettes très complets
donc ils savaient déjà faire la
différence entre les deux et ça se voit
dans les du coup ils ont ils ont mis tu
vois Charles Knight Charles Knight il a
représenté les deux et les deux sont
bien différenciés tu vois ah ouais là ça
tas dit mtrodon il a pas il a pas c'est
en fait la différence entre dimétrodon
et et daaposor c'est les pointes voilà
tu vois c'est pointes qu'il a sur la
crête ça c'est hedaposor mais déjà à
l'époque on savait déjà que hedaposor
avait les pointes sur la crête et pas
d'métrodon puisque là par exemple
Charles Knight qui l'a représenté comme
ça je sais pas si il a fait des
représentations des dapos Russies
évidemment il y a cellelà très connue
très très connue la fresque de yel je
crois qu'elle est à l'université d' yel
où on voit la différence entre les deux
donc là on a un peu
un un mix un peu bâtard un mix un peu
bâtard de dimétrodon et des daposor mais
donc il est passé là le Perm
d'accord on a trouvé le Perm ouais on a
trouvé le Perm bah je pense que les gens
qui ont refait le film qui ont restauré
le film l'ont l'ont fait avec les moyens
du bord mais n'ont probablement pas
demandé à un paléontologue dans quelord
resturé qui ont traduit le film du coup
ils n traduit comme ils ont pu peut que
c'est à la traduction que ça je pense
que ils ont traduit ils ont coupé les
machins les séquences tu sais pour
traduire et du coup pour insérer les
séquences où il fallait parce que en
traduisant il faut que tu enlèves les
anciens morceaux pour que tu remettes
les nouveaux et si ça trouves ça a été
mal remonté tout simplement ce serait
d'époque pour moi c'est d'époque parce
que moi je partais de l'hypothèse que c
en 2015 quand ils ont restauré le film
qui se sont trompés ah non en 2015 pour
restaurer le film tu fais pas ENF c'est
pas très compliqué quoi d'accord ah
ouais c'est possible que ce soit d'épqu
à mon avis c'est despqu ils ont juste
mal remonté les trucs c'est les
Américains qui ont mal remonté le truc
bah oui parce que souviens-toi qu'à
l'époque faut couper les morceaux de
film littéralement oui faut couper la
pellicule et après il faut la recoller
tu avais toute une histoire de col
spécial et cetera pour la passer donc du
coup pour insérer les encars de texte du
coup ou anciens en de Tex ils ont inséré
les trucs sauf que du coup tu coupes les
enc de Tex retrouves avec plein de
petits bouts là que tu dois
réassembler et puis tu es pas
paléontologue tu es pas familier du coup
ça devait aller là c'était non mais si
ça doit être et puis évidemment si tu as
pas bien numéroté tes trucs avant bah ça
donne ça ah oui c'est pas bête c'est pas
bête du tout c'est comme un puzzle que
tu as mal remonté d'accord donc mais on
reconnait bien donc la tête de dimérodon
là avec cette bouche sigmoïde et donc la
crête des daphosaurus h et et pas
d'herbes pas d'herbes dans le fond ça
c'est bien c'est pas des graminés ça non
ça ressemble à des fougères ça ressemble
plus à des prellles d'ailleurs en
réalité ce qui est plutôt précis comme
ça ressemble à des ouais je sa pas moi
je trouve que ça ressemble à des prell
ou des algues peut-être mais
brefing en tout
cas en tout cas c'est pas de l'herbe moi
je trouve ça ressemble pas à de l'herbe
c'est bienin mais ok on passe jamais
assez de temps à à débunker ce qui se
passe dans le décor mais pour l'instant
il y a pas d'Herb dans le F bah là il
mange des grosses fougères aborescantes
on dirait
ouais grosse
fougère là c'est pareil des fougèr et
des palmiers h donc ça ça marche ça
marche
ouais jusqu'à présent la végétation é
sur du palmier avant ouais ou ou ou la
végétation est pas mal du tout là on a
même des là c'est des là on a même des
cicades ah des cicass ouais
effectivement ouais les siadal les
sicadal les sicass Alex Rasti va me
n'est pas très de
imp moi si ça va pas une
vertèbre difficile d'en trouver
là-dedans ça au moins une vertèbre je je
connais pas toi tu es pluses dents non
ou des dents oui effectivement mais
ouais là ça c'est des c'est des sicas
complètement donc ouais en plus c'est
très très très très précis niveau de la
végétation en réalité hein non ça vache
bien allez tu regagnes un point tu as
perdu un point avec le
masosur je sais pas s'il a perdu un
point avec le masosauris parce que il
était bon celui-là osaur ouais
finalement c'est c'est un point qui est
tellement perdu qu'il revient il fait
tout le tour il fait tout le tour du C
ça c'est par je suis sûr que c'est la
traduction aussi ouais ah bah oui oui
oui tous les coups ils sont plantés
mososaur et du coup on aura peut-être un
mosazaur plus tard un vrai mosazur plus
tard mais qui sera appelé dimétrodon je
sais
pas bon il est pas très animé il est pas
très vivace ah si ah bouge il bouge il
est vivant il est vivant ah merde il a
vu la caméra cour mon dieu courz il a
une sale tête ou là ah bah là c'est
c'est tricératops de Charles Knight là
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure oui qui à
l'époque était pas appelé tricératops
d'ailleurs c'était un un AG Thomas
agathomas ouais c'est exactement lui là
il y a pas de il y a pas de doute donc
c'était un agathomas et c'est devenu un
Nomain du biome parce que le matos est
pas terrible donc à l'époque à l'époque
même les ils avaient CR créer une
famille qui s'appelle les agatomidés
dans laquelle se trouvait manospondilus
gigas notre tyrannosaure Tyrannosaurus
rex dans les agasses ok avec avec ça bah
oui c'est en fait c'est c'est c'est une
famille qui qui regroupait des trucs qui
étaient représentés par du matériel de
merde on sa pas ce que c'est c'est un
agatomidé
voilàou c'est assez marrant l'histoire
des agatomidou tu sais pas trop mettre
les choses oui c'est ça c'est si c'est
mal préservé c'est un agatomidé voilà ça
ressemble à tous ces groupes de
mammifère où tu sais pas trop les
classer tu fais un groupe tu sais ouais
tu fais un
groupeart poubelle exactement exactement
avec ses pointes ouais sur la colerette
comme ça qui était très à la mode à
l'époque avec les les les
ostéodermes c'est très fréquent ça même
encore aujourd'hui d'ailleurs on
représente beaucoup beaucoup d'animaux
préhistoriques avec des ostéodermes
comme ça sur le dos une s une sorte
d'armure parce que ça fait crocodile ça
fait primitif tu vois c'est ça donc il y
a beaucoup de gens qui qui cèdent à
enfin beaucoup de gens beaucoup de
d'artistes et de et de gens qui font des
représentations de dinosaures ou de
d'animaux préhistoriques qui cèdent un
peu à la facilité donner un air un petit
peu plus préhistorique à leur animal ils
leur mettent des
ostéodermes je dis ça mais même Victor
qui avait fait le la reconstitution de
l'edou mahadi lui a mis des ostéodermes
alors que vous en savez rien en fait bah
c'est surtout que dans les
soropodomorphes les seuls qui ont des
ostéodermes c'est les titanosaures donc
et c'était pas oui oui donc on est même
à peu près sûr que il devait pas en
avoir
mais ouais si si vous donnez si
vousoulez un petit indice comme ça voilà
si vous voulez donner un cachet primitif
à votre monstre à votre monstre de
fiction mettez-lui des ostéodermes ça
marche à tous les coups ouais ou
ou là pareil il se tourne vers la caméra
attention hein il est grand hein tu as
vu les arbres à côté c'est des plantes
ou je sais pas si c'est c'est c'est
toujours le problème c'est qu'il manque
toujours l'échelle ah on revient à
dimétrodom ou là
attention et pouf cit us mais du coup
c'est pour ça je me dis ils ont remonté
ça un peu dans Pourquoi tu mets deux
morceaux de di métrodon comme ça l'un
séparé par le je pense que tu as raison
mon avis ça complètement ils ont fait
comme ils ont pu et puis voilà ils sont
un peu
plantés donc qui entre deux dinosaures
[Rires]
[Musique]
fait
ça Chile dans le
[Rires]
Crétacé il y a les cicatrices du
remontage qui se voi ah le beau
stgosaure là il est présenté vraiment le
dos très très courbé hein c'est vraiment
le on est parti l'idée qu'on avait à
l'époque du stégosur
avec le et la tête qui revient en haut
comme ça après ça fait limite tortue ça
fait limite tortue ben en même temps euh
cé un peu l'idée de l'époque j'imagine
je P oui ben les tortues c'était entre
guillemets à l'époque c'est ce qu'on
pensait être les animaux les plus
primitifs enfin les reptiles les plus
primitifs les tortues ouais puisqu'ils
avaient un crâne anapside sans fausse
temp super dérivé alors qu'en réalité
c'est super dérivé mais bon à l'époque
c'était le l'archétype du reptile
primitif la tortue le crocodile c'était
les les archétypes du primitif Mo
l'iguan un peu aussi
non pas je sais pas non parce que il
ressemblait pas mal à des iguanes aussi
et les les dinosaures du Crystal Palace
je crois que c'est les iguanes qui les
ont ouais l'iguanodon ouais il était ins
ils l'ont pas mal inspiré non c'est vrai
il av peut-être VO les reptiles de
manère ah oh il bouge son ah c'est pas
mal il bouge les plaques donc ou il est
il est il est courbe comme ça c'est très
marrant mais non c'était pas bah c'est
pour c'est à l'époque on pensait que les
plaques étaient utilisé du coup pour
alors déjà faut faut voir il y a qu'une
seule rangée de plaque déjà ouais il y a
qu'une seule rangée de plaque alors que
normalement nor il y a deux rangées de
plaqu alterné et ça à l'époque il le
savait donc là ils ont un peu cédé je
pense que c'est au niveau du modèle ils
ont cédé un peu à la facilité mais si
vous regardez pareil le dessin de
Charles Knight qu' a fait du du stgosaur
bah là il y a un modèle là là il y a un
modèle voilà là on voit qu'il y a deux
rangées de plaques altern et en dessous
il y a le dessin exactement donc deux
rangées de plaques alterné donc à
l'époque il le savait déjà que il y
avait deux rangées de plaque alterné
donc là c'est juste le modèle ils ont
cédé un peu à la facilité je pense quand
ils ont créé le modèle ce qui est
marrant c'est que les plaques se
recourbent sur elles-même oui alors que
non c'est une plaque ça bouge pas ben la
la plaque peut pas se plier mais je
pense que l'idée c'était de montrer les
plaques articulées qui se qui
changeaient d'orientation pour la pour
se mettre le plus en face du soleil
possible puisquà l'époque il pensaient
que c'était utilisé pour la
thermorégulation HM il pensait qu'ils
utilisaient les plaques pour se
réchauffer du coup h donc ils avaient
peut-être C l'idée c'était de montrer
que les plaques bougeaient pour se
réorienter face au soleil ouais
peut-être alors les les on n pas fait
trop on n pas trop parlé des des pieds
parce que là cont j'ai l'impression
qu'ils ont mis ouais c doigts à l'avant
trois doigts à l'arrière donc ça au
moins ça au moins ça marche je sais pas
s'il y en a pas un derrière il y en a
peut-être un derrière ça a l'air d'être
CIN doigts quatre ou CIN doigts à
l'avant trois doigs à l'arrière donc les
trois doigts à l'arrière ça
marche ça c'est ça c'est bon
ouais c'est c'est aussi une solution de
facilité de leur mettre des des pattes
d'éléphant systématiquement B ça c'est
celle dont parlait tout à l'heure alors
tyranos ou hallosaur on sait pas trop je
pense que c'est tyrannosaure parce que
tyrannosaure avait déjà été découvert à
l'époque en 1915 il vachement frê pour
un tyranosaur ah bah tiens il manque un
bout peut-être qu'ils ont pas réussi à
le à le restaurer celui-là si ça se
trouve il y a des morceaux qui manquent
parce queou parce qu'ils ont ils étaient
trop trop
abîmés peut-être mais du coup c'est bien
qu'il le marque comme ça on peut savoir
où est-ce qu'il y a des morceaux qui
sont pas ouais
du coup ça va avec ton idée que le le
mauvais montage du dim et d'époque et
pas dû à la restauration de 2015 sinon
ils auraient juste sinon ils auraient
mis footage missing aussi sinon ils
auraient certainement signalé ouais
ouais donc le tyrannosaure découvert
ouais en 1915 si je ne m'abuse 1905 en
réalité 1905 1915 c'est même encore plus
tôt que je le croyais donc découvert en
1905 par barnom Bran décrit par
Osborne et qui donc a bien sa place ici
sil s'agit bien de Tyrannosaurus rex il
a l'air un peu fraê hein il est un peu
frê mais bon à l'époque on avait pas
grand-chose non plus hein enfin on avait
du B matos de Tyrannosaurus mais bon
ouis le crâne il devait être quand même
un peu plus non on avait pas un crâne le
crâne était oui ils avaient le crâne le
crâne holotype est effectivement mais le
faut se remettre dans l'idée de l'époque
c'est-à-dire que Tyrannosaurus c'est un
animal qui est quand même très
disproportionné quoi il a des tout
petits bras il a une très très grosse
tête on comprend pas trop alors du coup
quand on le
représente sur bah dans des dans des
produits culturels comme ça on veut pas
faire un animal qui qui est trop
disproportionné au point d'être
complètement euh comment dire au point
que les gens soient choqués de le voir
en disant ça pas pu exister sur le truc
c'est trop zarbi tu vois ou trop
incroyable mais ça pas l'air trop
incroyable donc je sais pas si c'est
tyranosaurus Rex mais est-ce qu'on se
disait pas aussi que peut-être les
morceaux qu'on avait trouvé
n'appartenaient pas forcément même
individu euh parce que si tu trouves une
grosse tête avec des petits bras
peut-être que tu vas dire qu'il y a de
individus euh peut-être mais attends on
va voir ce que c'était dans la peinture
la peinture originale est-ce que c'est
censé être un tyranosaurus Rex ah non un
allosaur c'est un Allosaurus c'est censé
être un Allosaurus et c'est pour ça
squelette de bronosur ok donc c'est
c'est pour ça qu'il a des gros bras une
petite tête du coup c'est pas
Tyrannosaurus rex d'accord donc ça va ça
va tout va bien tout tout va
bien c'est pas juste une licence
artistique pour le faire paraître plus
réaliste c'est pas exactement bien
proportionné non plus pour un hos mais
mettons ouais les bras sont toujours un
peu long enfin en partant du principe
que c'est bien un allosaur qui voulait
représenter parce que au final ils se
sont inspirés de la peinture de Kight ça
veut pas forcément dire oui c'est
exactement ça en il manque encore des
bouts donc plein de scientifiques
pensent que la terre est passée par
plusieurs
non que la terre est passé par plein of
bah j'imagine qu'avant c'était des
époques j'imagine qu'il parlait des
différentes époques de lastastwan donc
la dernière étant entre 30 et 40000 ans
donc ça doit être les air glaciaires non
peut-être peut-être les aires glaciaires
du coup le le ce qui manque avant c'est
une air glaciaire peut-être qu'ils
essayaient d'expliquer l'extinction des
dinosaures du coup dans ce morceau de
oui peut-être qu'ils expliquaient les
extinctions effectivement et que la
dernière pour eux c'était il y a 300000
ou 40000 ans ouais voilà donc ils
essayaient probablement d'expliquer
l'extinction des
dinosaures définitivement les
glaciations donc il voulait expliquer
l'extinction des dinosaures par les
glaciations
ce qui aurait été effectivement une
hypothèse valide à l'époque puisque
évidemment la découverte la météorite le
volcanisme tout ça ça date des années 80
donc à l'époque ils savaient pas à part
les glaciations ils auraient pas eu ils
auraient pas eu beaucoup d'autres
explications oui non sous la main pour
expliquer comment les dinosaures ont
disparu donc il le petit footage missing
là ça devait être les glaciations et
maintenant du coup on part sur les aires
glaciaires mais là on parle de
glaciation justement donc en fonction
des variations de température du sol les
glaciers les icebergs au lieu de fondre
augmenter en
nombre la musique ça fait vraiment
penser à de la musique encore
actuellement que tu mets dans les musées
tu sais l'expressionnisme
allemand c'est joli c'est moiou onait
Burton le dernier glacière a commencé
avec une tempête de neige habituelle
inabituel non avec The avec l'habituel
tempête de neige donc là on n montre
roceros sous une tempête de neige assez
moche le rinocuros la on va pas se
mentir je pense que même pour l'époque
c'était il a des lèvres tu as vu il a
des grosses lèvres il a des grosses
lèvres c'est roc roc sont des lèvres
tout va bien le mammouth un beau
mammouth la vache ça
c'est remte
ou le niveau de courbure des des
défenses de ce mamouth il luevient dans
les yeux
limite pauvre bête les mammouth à
l'époque on savait déjà très bien à quoi
ça ressemblait puisqu'on en avait déjà
retrouvé des congelés donc pour le coup
les glaciers des zones froides sont
descendent sur les zones
tempérées voici les glaciers avec le
ciel derrière attention le ciel animé et
tout ah on a répandu de la farine sur
far alors tous les animaux
préhistoriques sont morts pendant la
dernière aire glaciaire
alors ça je pense que déjà à l'époque
déjà on savait que c'est à la fin de
l'air glaciaire qu'il sont morts pas à
cause de l'air glaciaire plus pe on
savait on savait que les mammouth Laux
étaient les neux faut faut réfléchir à
ça en fait c'est comment on savait que
les mammouths laineux étaient les neux
et comment savait que les rhinocéros
lineux étaient les neux à l'époque on a
trouvé des momis voilà on a trouvé les
momis donc on savait que c'était des
animaux adaptés à l'air glaciaire donc
faut norement il était censé survivre
aussi donc à l'époque c'était déjà à
l'époque savait que c'est pas l'air
glaciaire qui les avait tué mais bel et
bien la fin de l'air glaciaire donc là
c'est une petite
facilité une petite
facilité de la part des des gens qui ont
qui ont fait ce petit cartel là là
ouais j'aime biencoup de la farine quand
même c'est
sympa c'est pas mal fait et là du coup
on
a le le le le signe direct que ça a été
fait en Europe là c'est centré sur
l'Allemagne en plus ah oui parce que les
américains aussi ils avaient des
glaciers mais ils a mais là il vous
montre
l'Europe super mamouth au moins les
défenses de celui-là ne remonte pas trop
oui
ouais c'est marrant qu'ils aient fait
des le même animal mais avec plusieurs
têtes différentes du coup h et pouf il
est mort et voilà for qui dépasse et ça
explique pourquoi on les retrouve gelés
aujourd'hui et non on pense que la Terre
va doucement rentrer dans un autre a
glacière qui sera
qui arrivera environ dans 10000 ans
et nous tremblons
d'anticipation ou oui ça à l'époque ils
étaient déjà conscients du fait que les
air glaciaes et interglaciaires
s'intercalaient et donc qu' on était en
ce moment dans un interglaciaire et
qu'on se dirigeait de fait vers une
nouvelle air glaciaire ah du coup ça
c'est la nouvelle musique the fin the
end bon ben il y avait pas mal de choses
à analyser dans ce documentaire alors
c'est un bon documentaire ou c'est un
mauvais documentaire bah je salue les
techniques de l'époque pour arriver à
nous transmettre que les animaux étaient
vivants et que il y avait toute une
ambiance autour et franchement il y a de
l'imagination il y a c'est vachement
bien moi je trouve et c'est mignon c'est
ça fait un peu penser
ouais bon ça fait penser à un projet de
de TPE
actuel mais mais je TR si tu as un
projet de TPE comme ça quand même c'est
vachement mieux que le projet de TPE de
base hein oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais ça ça fait penser un peu
au petits jeux d'enfant avec les avec
les figurines de dinosaures et tout ça
je trouve ça chouette mais c'est vrai
que c'est c'est l'ancienne vision des
dinosaures après bon
c'est le problème enin c'est pas un
problème c'est encore un truc très
actuel c'est dans la vulgarisation
scientifique il y a beaucoup de de
choses en fait qui passent à l'ASS quand
vous faites de la vulgarisation chez
dans certains médias qui vont préférer
utiliser des concepts qui sont un peu
plus vieux parce qu'ils sont plus simple
à vulgariser plutôt que de vulgariser
les idées qui sont un peu plus nouvelles
et qui sont un peu plus révolutionnaires
des fois qui sont pas forcément faciles
à à expliquer au grand public donc ça ce
documentaire c'est typiquement ce qu'il
fait il vire quelques idées de l'époque
qui étaient déjà là pourtant pour pour
garder l'ancienne vision des dinosaures
pour que bah ce soit peut-être plus
simple pour le grand public à avaler
parce que des fois on a tendance à se
dire que c'est plus simple pour des gens
qui n'y connaissent rien de rester sur
des vieux acquis ce qui en fait est pas
toujours vrai parce que quand tu
t'adresses à quelqu'un qui n'y connaî
rien au final que tu lui apprennes
quelque chose ou quelque chose d'autre
ça changera pas grand-chose à sa
vie il y a beaucoup de documentaires qui
sont comme ça qui qui plutôt que vous
apprendre des choses nouvelles vont
caresser ce que vous croyez déjà savoir
dans le sens du poil voilà
ok ben merci Sophie pour cette analyse
dites-nous ce que vous avez pensé de ce
documentaire dans les commentaires
est-ce que c'était mieux ou moins bien
que sur la terre des
dinosaures vachement mieux je il y a y a
un rétro il y a un petit goût de rétro
ouais c'est trop bien mais ça tu
rapportes le pop-corn nickel tu peux pas
battre la nostalgie tu peux pas battre
un niveau de nostalgie aussi lointain
que plus c'est loin plus c'est
nostalgique le premier premier
documentaire sur les dinosaures et il y
avait déjà deses différences non je
salut les fort vraiment B eff for bel
effort note bel effort sur 20 bel effort
sur 20 franchement non mais c'est
inér ok merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo et on vous dit à très
bientôt sur notre chaîne
salut